[Applause]
the x-men apocalypse
Jimmy
[Music]
[Applause]
millions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please we got ya
it's my favorite trip okay that just
that just sounds like you're being
murdered that's not a good
that's disturbing that part hello ladies
and gentlemen I'm Conan O'Brien at
comic-con
at comic-con I'm known as Superman in
the streets but ant-man in the sheets
[Applause]
okay guy yelling no you're not you seem
to be welling down does that guy know
yeah I am very sad to say it is our last
night here at comic-con yeah the ending
will be particularly sad because I'm
going out John snow style
[Applause]
Andy Andy asked to speak with me and
then I want to be the first step and the
last step hey isn't this exciting
you heard right the cast of x-men
apocalypse
that's great
yes here's a spoiler I appear in the
film as storms little brother
partly cloudy so look I'll just walk
around partly cloudy
hmm I've learned so much I've loved
being a Comic Con I've learned so much
about comic-con yeah yeah I learned the
official acronym of comic-con is SDCC
yeah to the people attending comic-con
SDCC stands for sweaty drunk and
carrying crap
the spider-man have to put their stuff
down to shoot a web Thor is like lift
with the back yesterday I don't know
anyone saw me I walked around the floor
of comic-con for just like 30 seconds
yeah briefly briefly and I saw a sexy
woman dressed as a cyclops yeah guess
she was telling guys hey buddy my eye is
up here please let's keep in mind the
show is free hey on Thursday I hope you
saw this on Thursday William Shatner
read from his book the autobiography of
james t kirk then he read an excerpt
from his next book called still milking
it
fans who attended the Star Wars panel do
you hear this we're treated they were
treated to a special surprise Star Wars
concert it was incredible apparently
unfortunately the concert ended
tragically when Jabba the Hutt jumped
into a mosh pit hundreds dead apparently
dead people applauding yeah glad I
wasn't there